Welcome back everyone Ryan Reynolds just dropped
another Deadpool 3 teaser confirming some really
cool details about the movie and how it fits into
the MCU and a big Crossover with the events of
Loki season 2 so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll be getting Loki season
2 episodes way before Deadpool 3 happens so I'll
explain how that connects with Deadpool 3 Because
by the time the events of the movie take place
Loki Sylvie Mobius the others at the TVA will
have already encountered this Kang the Conqueror
will have already seen Kang during Ant-Man and
the wasp. Deadpool 3 won't be released at least
right now until the end of 2024 so a ton of stuff
will have happened when that picks up the reason
is not listed on the Marvel Phase 6 schedule is
because they only announced it after they did
their big Comic-Con panel but it is meant to be a
Marvel Phase 6 movie and this movie schedule will
already shift a little bit because Spider-Man 4
with Tom Holland wasn't on the Comic-Con schedule
that's supposed to happen in July 2024 right now
and if you look at the schedule the Thunderbolts
movie is listed then right now meaning that Marvel
is going to move the Thunderbolts movie probably
so like all these Marvel movies starting with
the Thunderbolts will shift by like one date so
Thunderbolts will happen in November 2024 taking
the Deadpool 3 date and Deadpool 3 will probably
wind up releasing in February 2025 Fantastic Four
will shift another movie date everything will just
shift down the line by one movie but just to
be clear the Thunderbolts movie is meant to be
the end of Marvel phase five I've already done
a big video about that so I'll post it in the
links below because they're introducing a really
really big character previously the Fantastic Four
movie was going to be the beginning of Marvel
phase six now that's kind of Deadpool 3 but
you probably spotted the big teasers that Ryan
Reynolds just dropped out of nowhere Deadpool
versus Miss minutes confirming that the TVA is a
big plot point during the movie that's why he did
that confirming some of the plot details of the
movie confirming that they're going to be major
characters in the movie and their big thing
is protecting what they're told is the main
timeline the sacred timeline but heading into
Loki season 2 Kang the Conqueror is the one
who's currently winning the Kang multi verse War
meaning he's the person who's in charge of the TVA
telling them what to do not that he who remains
variant the more benevolent variant so when Loki
season 2 picks up the timeline that they've been
protecting for all time always as the saying goes
is a totally different timeline than the one that
we just saw during season one the original sacred
timeline when they call it the sacred timeline
was meant to be everything that we saw during
the Marvel Infinity Saga of movies up to Avengers
end game like right up to the Loki season 1 after
Sylvie killed he who remains because he wasn't
controlling the timeline with his technology
anymore the timeline rebooted and in the second
version of events the Kane Multiverse War 2.0
played out and currently this Kang the Conqueror
is winning but the idea is that it's still going
on like you're still having all these incursions
the kang Multiverse war is one of the big reasons
the incursions are happening not the only reason
like Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness was all
about Doctor Strange in Scarlet Witch causing
incursions so there are multiple reasons why
incursions happen but the kang Multiverse war is
a big part of it that's why at the end of Loki
season 1 when he comes back to the TVA and the
timeline is different so many crazy things are
happening people running all over the place like
they're in the middle of a giant War like what do
we fix we don't know he hasn't told us yet and
they're talking about that version of Kang the
Conqueror giving them orders about what to fix
first you still have all these variants of Kang
running around in other timelines battling it out
with each other for Supremacy Loki season 2 will
be Loki trying to get the band back together
so to speak having to re-explain everything
that happened to everybody who doesn't remember
the events of season one and that's basically
everybody except for Loki himself Sylvie because
she was protected from the changes of the timeline
and Kang the Conqueror himself we already got the
Loki season 2 trailer at d23 I've done a big video
for it so I'll link it at the end of this and down
in the description below but they will probably
not defeat Kang entirely because we have Avengers
5 Kane Dynasty just like Ant-Man will probably
not defeat Kang but the idea is that Loki Mobius
Sylvie the other TB age and regular hunters will
regain a level of control over the TVA itself and
just continue trying to do what they're supposed
to be doing protecting timelines now because the
larger Multiverse protecting reality from the
really really bad Nexus events the funny thing
though is that because we know that Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty is happening Avengers six Secret
Wars they have to be unsuccessful like they have
to fail at some point because the whole idea with
Secret Wars is that all of reality collapses to
a single World a single timeline controlled by
Kang the Conqueror the whole idea is that this
version of Secret Wars is probably going to turn
more around Kang the Conqueror than it is around
God Emperor Doom but I do expect Dr Doom to be
introduced to the MCU by then so he'll probably be
a part of this version of Secret Wars in some way
but Deadpool 3 is meant to take place before all
the Kang Dynasty Secret Wars stuff while Loki the
TVA are still running around dealing with the Kang
Multiverse war and other big Nexus events trying
to actually do the job that they're supposed to
be doing because they said the movie is going to
take place in the MCU Deadpool coming to the MCU
with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine probably going to be
based on the events of Deadpool 2 just because it
all lines up perfectly like they don't have have
to bend over backwards to explain how this all
works at the end of Deadpool 2 Deadpool takes
Cable's time travel device wreaks utter havoc
on his own Fox Marvel timeline changing a whole
bunch of stuff the way you explain the events of
the Wolverine Origins movie is that that version
of Ryan Reynolds Deadpool the bad version is meant
to be a variant of Deadpool another version from
another similar but slightly different timeline
where the events of Deadpool's life played out
differently the way they explain timelines during
Loki season 1 is that they're kind of like bundles
of rope with a couple minor variations on events
that all exist within the same timeline when
things are really different that's when they
Branch off and become Nexus events and if they
go on long enough if they go past the red line
Point those branches turn into fully alternate
universes he who remains Kang was preventing a
lot of that from happening like keeping the
different variants within a certain range so
like this bad version of Deadpool and Wolverine
Origins is from a timeline that's very very close
to the events of this version of of Deadpool's
timeline and as of the events of Deadpool 2 he
is part of the main Fox Marvel timeline that's why
I say Wolverine Origins is like a variant timeline
of Deadpool it's the same idea in Spider-Man no
way home where you have the three Peter Parker's
Toby Maguire Andrew Garfield Spider-Man coming
to the MCU the events of their lives played out
a little bit differently but they go home
to their universes at the end of that film
The only difference this time is at the end of
Deadpool 2 Deadpool causing Nexus offense left
and right in his own Fox Marvel timeline the same
way that Loki and Sylvie did during season one
like wreaking utter Havoc they've been all kinds
of rumors about crazy cameos like a version of
galactopool you have to imagine Deadpool messing
up one of his timelines so badly that it leads to
a version of Galactic pool happening and that's
one of the reasons why the TVA gets involved
because he's doing things that lead to that kind
of craziness naturally the TVA is still trying to
do their job would try to stop him arrest him and
whoever's with him enter Hugh Jackman Wolverine
I'll talk about Wolverine in a second Deadpool
is to blame for most of the events of Deadpool 3
he just kind of ropes in Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
for the fun where you get to Deadpool versus Miss
minutes is after Deadpool's arrested by the TVA
brought in for processing like everybody else
Miss minutes gives him the whole tutorial on the
Kang Multiverse War why the TVA exists to protect
the timeline now multiple timelines because the
larger Multiverse in Deadpool being Deadpool not
really listening to her or carrying causing as
much trouble for them as possible doing whatever
he wants to do the same way Sylvie kind of walked
all over them for a long time there are a couple
really cool things that they're introducing during
Loki season 2 like really dangerous ideas really
dangerous objects that will probably figure into
the events of Deadpool 3 as well the reason Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine is such a big part of the
plot is probably because Deadpool pulls him
from the fox Marvel timeline before the events of
the Logan movie that's the future of his own Fox
Marvel timeline during that second pick Deadpool
three teasers they released a little while ago
they said they weren't going to completely erase
what happened in that movie this is them talking
about it hi hi how are you you have questions
yes I I had a lot of questions I'm sure you had
a lot of questions but rest assured we're going
to answer them right now like for example how is
Wolverine alive yeah after Logan Logan uh takes
place in 2029 totally separate thing Logan died
in Logan not touching that what actually happens
in our film is what that means is that Deadpool
you Winks him from earlier in his timeline when he
does that things go off the rails this Wolverine
becomes a variant of the original the events
of the fox Marvel Universe continue and the
Logan movie still winds up happening but our new
Wolverine variant in Deadpool variant exists the
same way that Loki exists now in the MCU they're
still the main versions technically but they're
also technically variants of The Originals and
if you really think about it the TVA is a MCU
creation it's core MCU even though the way they
exist inside the Multiverse they're kind of like
a pocket Dimension is a little bit different
just the sheer Act of them interacting with
the TVA characters makes Deadpool 3 take place
in the MCU but what they really mean when they
say the movie is going to be in the MCU is that
the movie will set up Deadpool and Wolverine to
return an Avengers 6 Secret Wars so even though
they'll mess with a bunch of events in Marvel
movies like he will mess with the timelines of
a bunch of other Marvel films I think that most
of the movie moments that he messes with from the
previous Marvel movies will be from the fox Marvel
movies that's why I say the vibe is more like
Deadpool kills the fox Marvel universe that's
part of the joke like he messes with a lot of
the fox Marvel movies there's been a lot of
rumors about them bringing back the fox Fantastic
Four characters for Cameo scenes I think that's
how they would bring them back is that he messes
with the events of those movies in those timelines
and even if Deadpool does completely wreck the
fox Marvel Universe timeline during Secret Wars
the whole idea is that they fixed the Multiverse
after they defeat Kang so any universal timeline
that was destroyed or wrecked will mostly go
back to the way it was mostly I say the larger
goal in secret Wars is to fix things in a way that
will explain a bunch of mutants X-Men characters
popping up in the MCU all of a sudden like this
is why you didn't know about us before because
of Secret Wars that's one of the reasons why they
haven't been hyping up the new MCU X-Men movie as
much because they're mostly waiting till Secret
Wars happens to do that in Marvel phase 7 will
be hardcore X-Men mutant space stuff Deadpool 3
characters like Namor who's a mutant they just
introduced Miss Marvel being a mutant it's just
the tip of the spear like just a teaser of things
to come we'll see more mutants and X-Men stuff
happening in the MCU piecemeal up until Secret
Wars but like really big X-Men movies probably
not going to happen until after Secret Wars Ryan
Reynolds is always really good about dropping
teasers and hints like this as we go along so of
course we'll do new videos about Deadpool 3 when
he does that but if you have any big questions
about how this is all going to work or how the
characters are all going to come together just
write it in the comments below we'll get a new
Loki season 2 trailer probably sometime early
next year because those episodes will drop next
summer the next big Marvel Disney plus series is
going to be what if season 2 and then the secret
Wars series trailers for that stuff really really
soon they're also going to be a couple brand new
Marvel movie trailers really soon as well too
click here for that new Ant-Man Quantum Mania Kang
video and click here for my Loki season 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!